[Music]
look who just sent me a text addy
McAllister what should I say just play
it cool
welcome to the world inside your phone
where everyone is expected to ask one
way their whole life Wow my name is Jean
and I'm supposed to be a man you know
man who cares
my problem is I have more than one
emotion like this out huh
please tell me you weren't laughing just
now what if you get sent out on the
phone making the wrong face say I don't
make the right face then I would finally
fit in sweety dude you're so handsome
when you make that face I think he's
ready now no that's our user Alex we
have an incoming text we are go for met
OOP me just make it the wrong face hmm
huh what the heck welcome to the loser
lounge where the emojis who never get
used hang out what's up my pop I'm an
emoji you gotta have some sort of
purpose here I'm gonna help you we need
to get off the phone and find the source
code then I can fit in let's roll my
Felicia
first we have to get through this
firewall with all of this girlfriend's
name again
it was Tina tonight Karen Sarah
I want to say Lupita but that doesn't
feel right now I'm saying out loud
I think you're pretty cool just the way
you are
my feelings are huge
maybe I meant to have more than just one
emotion surmise candy crush define sweet
never eaten another piece of candy ever
again
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once okay son
what do we do after we go potty should
we wash our hands
[Music]